what's a good test to see if something
is missing from your story whether
there's not enough Intrigue the suspects
don't seem real the stakes aren't High
Enough it's very common problem
especially in first couple drafts
to have things not as suspenseful or
falling flat or not making things as
challenging on your
investigator as you should it's very
common so first of all give yourself
some Grace take a breath
I like to Workshop my work I always
Workshop my work because even if I think
maybe there's enough suspension
Challenge and mystery and authenticity
uh my writer's group will definitely
point out if there's not and that's good
it's good to have that accountability so
I I'm a big promo proponent of writers
groups and
uh community in in writing because once
you find the right Community you'll
you'll start
to well your work will get a lot
stronger because and you don't have to
rely so much on your yourself
because they'll Point things out for you
and that's really helpful although
sometimes painful but really helpful
so
then
the question becomes how do I fix this
all right it's falling flat things
aren't as suspenseful
I
like to make sure that there are
obstacles intention
in every scene
and so when I'm going back through to
edit second or third draft or more
that's one of my checklists I want to
see if there's something
[Music]
like a tension happening at the end of
each scene like a little baby even if
it's just a little baby Cliffhanger
we're just or a little baby mystery
you're leaving us with something
unresolved in almost every scene it
could be an emotional element right
between characters or a relational
element
it could be more something to do with
the case at hand
when in order to make sure that's not
happening with the case or like to make
sure your eye I again this is why I love
making a case File because I can clock
I'm going to clock that trail of
evidence from the beginning to the end
and I'm gonna before I even get to the
script or the page I'm going to make go
through and
as if
I'm the criminal committing the crime
and then I'm the investigator
investigating the crime and I want to
make sure that the trails of evidence
make sense and that they have a lot of
tension and I want to make sure that
um my criminal smart and my investigator
is really smart
um so it's for me it's a lot of pre-work
to see that that's all happening and it
really just kind of takes practice too
you kind of write a lot of Limp things
before things start to really sing and
then sort of innately
you get a sense like oh this is if your
gut's kind of telling you like yeah this
is just isn't
there's just not enough tension here
there's just nothing really happening
there's not enough suspense I think it's
important to listen to that as well
because 10 times out of 10 that there's
a problem there I Rely a lot on my
instinct and the more you write the
sharper Your Instinct becomes I think
if you're serious about it
um
I mean it's such a great question
because I'm trying to think over the 20
years I've been doing this how did I
learn that and it was really a lot of
it wasn't a book learning you know it
really wasn't a thing that I read in a
book or watched in a video or took a
class on you know it was very much just
practicing the craft knowing first of
all what goes into a great Crime Story
what makes it sing what makes it pop
what makes it binge-worthy and then
testing it out on my writer group
and then just in using my instinct
your story Instinct really I guess I
wouldn't call it that's good that could
be a book too stories that's good I like
that good you put the crossbones yeah
the case File that you begin is this a
metaphorical file where you'll do it on
your computer or do you actually have
like a manila folder where you create
like your own sheet with different
pieces of evidence and log things and
that would be super fun I've never done
that but that would be really fun
um I yeah I usually just start
everything by hand I'll write notes and
notes and notes by hand and then it ends
up on my computer
and just becomes a computer file you
know where I've sort of done all the
exercise of the case so
but I kind of like yeah creating an
actual case File that'd be fun create
your own evidence pieces yeah there's
your interactive game yeah
so you're doing this as if you are the
investigator from the POV of the
investigator first the investigator then
the criminal or vice versa I mean you
can do either way but
um I try to take both points of view
like okay if I'm the criminal and I want
to create a crime I'm going to commit a
crime I'm gonna walk myself through it
from the beginning to post and then what
did I do how did that happen and then as
an investigator I can't say oh I'm
coming I've just been thrown into this I
have to investigate this crime
um what from the beginning to the end of
solving it what am I coming across
um
because right we in the real world
um
you know a detective or a investigator
may not find everything
um
which is really I think good we want we
don't want our main we don't want our
heroes to find everything either but I
need to know both I as the creators the
goddess of this world I need to know
both I don't always use everything it's
probably not wise to use everything
because otherwise it'd be just like a
game of matching right it'd be too easy
but I need to know
what I need to know from both points of
view what happened so that I can
successfully play that cat and mouse
game
it's like a chess game
it does and you know speaking of which
you mentioned the you know the
investigator doesn't always have
everything
in real life when a case turns cold
quote unquote is it because there's not
enough evidence there's not enough
funding what's the usual reason why a
case is sort of tucked away right
there's a lot of reasons
um a case officially becomes cold after
12 months
so then it goes into that designation so
during that first 12 months it gets you
know a lot of attention
um it could be because there's just not
enough evidence that leads to a
particular person of interest
uh a lot of times there's not enough
person power
to investigate there's not enough funds
these police departments are severely
underfunded there's not enough people
um there's yeah it's all of these things
that happen
um there's a lot of cold cases in our in
our country a lot and
oh it really just they're yeah really
kind of Fizzles out because of sort of a
combination of all those things
and it doesn't mean that it won't ever
get solved but it it needs at some point
a little boost of something whether it's
a person just going further into
investigating to make those connections
money for that person to do that and
then of course you know when a crime
happens that's not the end like then
crimes keep happening so then the
workload right there's a constant
workload coming in every day it's not
like you can just stop solve that crime
well and you know put a pause on the
world pause everybody no more crimes a
second I gotta solve this one there's
constantly more and more
stacking up so it's uh it's a workload
problem as well
and are there some non-profits that you
can kind of different people can sort of
crowdsource their efforts to solve cold
cases there are there are and
um
different you know there's all there's
actually probably lots lots of them I
got involved with the Cold Case
Foundation
they are a National Organization that's
a non-profit and they
really solved the hardest to solve cases
they it's it's free you know they're all
but funded through
um
donations and you know not
any sort of outside other you know
agency money or anything like that and
and so there are organizations like that
like them that will help people
um they are awesome and they are growing
and they rely a lot on retired law
enforcement and retired investigators to
come in and volunteer their time too
which I think is awesome because you
have you know people coming in who have
Decades of of information you know
knowledge about how to do this and the
time so and the intuition and the
intuition right yeah interesting what's
better a victim we can root for in a
story
or a villain we can love to hate
depends on the story type of the 11
crime story types that I talk about and
teach there's one Crime Story type
that's different than all the rest and
that's called the caper and this is a
very very popular fun Crime Story type
because in that crime story type We are
rooting for the villain the villain is
our hero
the villain is the bad guy and we love
to root for the villain because
typically the villain has been wronged
in their past and now they're taking
Justice into their own hands and we're
like yes right because how many times
have maybe we've been wronged and we
couldn't do anything about it and we
just would have loved to take justice in
our own hands and like avenge our our
crime or our Injustice or and so this we
love this crime story type so I I don't
think it's an either or situation I
think there's just sometimes we love
this we love this crime story type of
rooting for the villain
um Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
classic example Thelma and Louise
classic example we just write like one
of my favorites
um Heller high water which came out a
few years ago because quickly be and was
kind of quiet like just kind of came and
went but it's brilliant Caper about
familial love rooted in familial love
about two brothers
who commit crimes in order to avenge
their mothers wrong something that bad
that happened to their mother right
who's not going to root for that even
though they're they're doing terrible
things
um all of the oceans movies are Caper
Italian job and that and those villains
it's more of a team right it's more of a
multiple
um it's a obviously it's a team sport
but you know a character team care of
characters and they're just kind of fun
I don't I think there's maybe some
avenging that goes on definitely in the
Italian job but in the oceans 11 when
like it's it's really just fun to watch
them get away with this big crime and
sort of mess with the system so
uh that is I think in its own just the
story type that we
love
um
separate from but not necessarily
unequal from the stories where we get
very invested in the victims and we want
to see them it's just a different story
type where you're focusing more on the
victim's story and how does that get
resolved and redeemed and so I just
think they're very they're just kind of
different but not necessarily
when it's better than the other I guess
so
yeah
what makes a satisfying ending
I believe that a satisfying ending
does not necessarily have to be
a closed happy everything gets wrapped
up in a little bow but it needs to be
cathartic in that
whatever
on Injustice was set up at the beginning
needs to be righted whatever chaos
happened to this person at the beginning
needs to somehow be ordered there has to
be
an element of redemption ins even if
it's just a little bit we can see that
the world is just a little bit brighter
for that person that hero or that victim
um I think that's the catharsis we're
all looking for in this genre and that
we're all looking for in ourselves
our our own worlds
and would it depend you said earlier
like cozy Mysteries okay that's more
maybe light-hearted and in the end you
know the the sun'll shine again and and
there's the harmony restored to the
neighborhood but maybe girl with a
dragon tattoo not so much right right
right right right I mean you have the
Hallmark Mysteries which are Super
popular right and they're great and like
could binge watch those the whole day
those in the Christmas movies
um and that's there's definitely a place
for that it's lovely
um and then you have something more like
what happens on lifetime which is
definitely the more the genre of women's
stories and women wanting to be event
like wanting to have right right
restored because
um think bad things have happened to
them and so there's that sort of a
little bit darker level
um of story yeah and then we can go
Silence of the Lambs or
um
what did you just say uh you're with the
Dragon Tattoo yes where which I I love
Swedish Noir I love North that that
Nordic Noir
um love it it's because it's you're
right it doesn't there is a a satisfying
ending in that she helps them
catch this horrible person who's been
trafficking women it's
horrifying you know kind of really dark
and grisly but she does help avenge all
that and so it's extremely satisfying
um ending
but you could you know you kind of get
money getting there getting to the end
of that
and the writer has his own interesting
story too and mystery behind his death
oh Diddy I didn't read about that well
there's different theories but anyway
yeah I have no opinion on either one but
um yeah there's been mystery behind it